like clockwork as soon as the Philippine
Supply Mission nears the second Tomas sh
in the South China Sea Chinese ships
emerge cutting across their paths Manila
calls them dangerous Maneuvers it has
put the lives of our Personnel at risk
Beijing says they're lawful and
restrained this Philippine Coast Guard
vessel we are on attempting for a second
time to get closer to the second Tomas
sh but you can see that Chinese Maritime
militia vessel already moving to close
the opening as well as that Chinese
Coast Guard vessel over there our ship
weaves this way through but from afar we
see a Chinese Coast Guard vessel
blasting water cannon onto a Philippine
supply boat confrontations like this
have become the norm speaking at a forum
in Hawaii Philippine president ferdinan
Marcus Jr described the situation as
dire he accused China of building bases
closer and closer to the Philippines and
said this has for forced Manila to turn
to allies and neighboring countries who
have overlapping claims for support we
are now in the midst of uh uh
negotiating our own code of conduct for
example with Vietnam because we are
still waiting for the code of conduct
between China and the and Asia and the
progress has been rather slow
unfortunately Beijing says it won't
honor an agreement separate from the one
currently under discussion and defended
its activities in the disputed Waterway
China's construction activities on its
own territory fall entirely within
China's sovereignty and other countries
have no right to make irresponsible
remarks China has demanded Manila to
away this warship that's been
deliberately grounded since 1999 but the
Philippines insist it has Sovereign
rights as the second Thomas sh is just
200 km away from its Shores and nearly a
thousand from China Barn below Al jazer
in the South China
Sea
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer